oui ok c'est un choix 900 combien de
temps vous êtes sur deux mois de retard
ok ok ça marche par chèque sans faute
merci madame merci beaucoup
ah ben oui je vais bien que ça va aller
oui d'un petit fail a pas école il va
s'occuper de moi ok ça marche ben abid
hammadou je te prends pour autant dire
la drogue et après quoi j'ai pris appui
sur ouais je la construis voilà la
tenture voir tout jamais colossaux
frérot jeudi de shahrivar excité trois
jeux
[Musique]
préfet et respire frère au respect
visite à crier tous les feux rouges et
sucrées qui me fait peur heureusement
que j'ai speed et 10 mois merci les gars
et moi merci frère regarde les quelle
heure on arrive en avance était détendue
est ce que ça joue de ouf
il abuse lé président n'arrive pas en
avance tu vois ils sont tranquilles mais
les pdg ils ont du style et ils ont
duflot il faut encore star ça fait
soixante dix une fois quand tu le mets à
combien compressé non je t'ai dit palmer
dessus arrête de me stresser temps plein
c'est bon je les habille déjà mis de
façon on s'en fout là mais je les ai
jamais dit non mais témoin ce qu'il a
fait il a mis les chaussettes blanches
témoin ces choses débloquent joueurs
seront prêts le rappel de couleur et la
chemise derrière apple droulers montrer
s'il faut deux roues comme ça vient
jouer les personnes redirige sur cette
carte je sais ce qu'est ce que je vais
vous servir
de l'eau de l'eau pour maurane plate ou
gazeuse bah je vais prendre un diabolo
fraise au moins ça vous fera 5 euros
cinquante cinq ans que vous encaissez
maintenant 5,51 grève du mois se
moquaient la colle à moi mais là le
compte comptait bien si jamais à côté
mais avant tout la monnaie atterrir sans
thiago l'ophrys comprenez rien
incroyable et qui repêchent bonjour j'ai
rendez vous avec monsieur bernier oui ce
serait vous êtes ousmane bah c'est la
porte au fond du couloir
merci
oui je peux le passé enfin champion
avance ousmane oui ousmane jean mane
envahir entre autres mets toi à l'aise
vas-y je t'en prie rentrer quand c'est
juste que cal il était en avance mais
alors y'a pas de soucis
asseyez-vous je suis à vous dans 2
minutes mais k way we sandra ouais ils
sont là ok écoute tu les fais patienter
dix minutes bon je termine le brief avec
les nouveaux collaborateurs là ok ça
marche à tout à la jarrie 20 hockey où
ça va et toi
ouais pas trop relou pour venir chanter
mieux du monde type on va écouter déjà
bienvenue et big city assez farce on est
plutôt bien ici et colas je suis ravi
que vous soyez là tous les deux vraiment
merci j'ai reçu vos dossiers
pardon tu veux un café ah non non je
vous remercie j'étais à tout de suite
ici on se vouvoie pas d'accord ça me
fout des angoisses ses chères études
ok tu sors vingt autres dans sa vallée
store merci eric ok bah écoutez moi je
veux que vous sachiez que vous avez été
recruté parce qu'ici la boîte se base
uniquement sur le mérite et le potentiel
des candidats et moi je vous ai repéré
car je suis convaincu vous avez le
profil idéal pour mener à bien les
missions de vous présenter pour
commencer est ce que vous êtes un petit
peu renseigné déjà sur ce qu'on fait ici
oui un nazi je sais que beach est issu
l'entreprise qui a pour but de faciliter
la transition vers le grand paris enfin
si je me trompe pas vrai si on fait un
talus la brochure
c'est exactement ça ça on va avancer
vers le grand paris est pour ça qu est
ce qu'on fait on va réaménager la
périphérie c'est à dire on va créer des
nouveaux espaces propre moderne pour
accueillir les nouvelles lignes de métro
à vis à vis des prolongements la petite
couronne en couronne
tous ces trucs là voyez le délire cool
d'ailleurs vous vivez où vous vous êtes
dans lieux jamais bougé ouais toujours
vécu également moi je viens de déménager
du côté de montreuil ligne 9
c'est sa croix de chavaux cool
du coup vous connaissez bien le terrain
on est quand même d'accord pour dire que
là-bas il ya des familles qui vivent
juste dans des conditions insalubres à
quoi enfin je ne veux pas et sans
déconner envie au 19e siècle c'est
dégueulasse c'est même pas aux normes
je ne sais pas qu'est ce que vous en
pensez vous ben oui si on pouvait faire
quelque chose pour la qualité de vie
là-bas l'améliorer en tout cas parce que
les conditions là-bas et son besoin et
une flore abl grave
du coup l'idée voilà c'est ça on va
créer des lotissements des sens et
encore quand je suis descendue en
dessous la demande est là sur le coup on
a des architectes de malades on va faire
des espaces propres green des trucs avec
du style compliqué mais pour arriver à
cette finalité
il faut que les gens qui vivent là-bas
accepte de partir le plus vite possible
ok il ya autre chose il faut qu'on les
fasse partir dans les trois mois
c'est la deadline parce que sinon on va
laisser passer des contrats et si on n'a
pas les contrats evs a pas de cdi
pas de prime votre voiture de fonction
enfin vous voyez le hockey vous êtes
chauds baba cool moi aussi ça tombe bien
allez on perd pas de temps on rentre
direct du livre du sujet ça c'est les
dossiers avec les fameux locataires qui
veulent pas partir ok
non si vous avez compris ce qui vous
attend c'est quoi l'objectif préparer le
grand paris j'imagine y aller ça c'est
mon gars sur ça on va faire des belles
choses légales
ouais oui merde je vous laisse
épluchez ça moi j'ai une réunion parce
que pain sur la planche on se retrouve
tout à l'heure ok outsider cheval et
guzmán où il habite toujours comme ça
toi oui c'est pas une question piège
mais juste prochaine fois et vite
peut-être voudrais pas qu'ils aient peur
d'accord ok paul costa
allez dans quelle zone de montredon
[Musique]